thank you good morning everyone thank
you for coming this hour this morning so
this is joint work with moaning oh and a
photo so I'm going to talk about
interactive proofs and we're going to
talk about having an interactive proof
where the verifier is actually
distributed so this is gonna be our
prove earth throughout our talk
it's nice guys the honest proofer so we
have interactive proofs and I'm we saw
them a lot this week and I'm not gonna
go over the definitions we have
completeness we have soundness
okay respect to some language l as we
saw they're very useful we like to study
them they're actually led to the notions
of PCP and zero knowledge they're very
powerful that IP equals please face but
I want to just for one second step back
and ask a when to use an interactive
proof
so maybe general setting is that the
verifier is some somehow computationally
bounded and we think of the Hoover is
unbounded and this drunk uber wants to
prove something to this week verifier
you can also have double efficient
protocols where the Hoover the prover is
still computationally bounded but the
verify just runs in less computational
time you can also talk about approver
that had a verify that has limited space
okay and the prover doesn't have this
limitation and in general what we want
we use them when the povel is somehow
the verifier somehow you know his handle
is tied in some way and the pool doesn't
have this limitation so the limitation
that I want to talk about today is
actually well the verifier is not a
single centralized unit it's a
distributed protocol so instead of this
single verifier but we're going to have
here is actually a distillate auto color
and I'm going to define exactly what I
mean and already see a question
so actually it's not the first time I
got this comment I think I used to do it
the other way and then somebody asked me
why you do it and somehow I saw it's
them that got stuck
okay so I think in the video maybe we
can just you know ok so just before I
define the formal model a some
motivation so already you vile at the
beginning of the workshop works out this
is like a snippet from his slides we
talked about this modular approach where
he takes this poof system and extracts
out an information theoretic setting and
then we have this crypto compilers and
such and so this model one benefit is it
is information theoretic and we're going
to talk about mainly communication and
they not have well at least until the
end of the talk I need computational
assumptions another motivation so maybe
the verifier is just happen to be it's
not a single unit maybe it's a whole
network ok I don't know maybe it's the
Bitcoin network or just people around
the world that they somehow want to join
jointly verify this proof and lastly we
talked a lot about the efficiency of
these protocols and a lot about the
efficiency of the prover and the
verifier one way to gain efficiency in
the verifier say okay maybe my verifier
is not my weak my weak phone or smart
watch ok it's a I don't know Google
wants to prove something to Facebook and
Facebook has a lot of computers so they
can distribute this verifier ok to run
it more more quickly
okay so let's see the model so the
smaller was actually introduced by Cola
shaman Saxena as a journal is a ssin of
a common cotton and Pellegrino five so
they defined like the non-interactive
version and the general as I generalize
this to them the interactive version so
we already saw this model I think
yesterday and also so Henry and I talked
about it and Justin also talked about it
elite in the open problem session so we
have approvers and we have two verifiers
and their input is split between X 1 and
X 2 and then the prover can send
messages to both and they can
communicate and there's all sorts of
questions here can Ally stalked Bob and
Bob to Alice and and how exactly the
communication it goes and it's different
model really is somewhat different I
want to take this to to the extreme so
what happens when I add the third guy
okay so now I have three parties and my
input is distributed between three
parties another really question here
okay do I do this triangle can any party
talk to any party that's and I can say
okay maybe only one conductor two and
three conductor to have different
configurations really push this fur
forward I can just have n parties okay
so I have one prover I have n parties
and computational units the input is
going to be distributed between these
and units I have x1 to xn and now I have
some graph G that defines the
communication pattern that they can talk
any graph G okay I'm only gonna assume
throughout this talk that the graph is
connected okay if the graph is not
connected then really you have nothing
that you can do and now my input okay is
actually gonna define it's going to be
defined by all the x1 to xn
the single individual input and also
this graph G okay so I'm just gonna put
it also as part of the input so not
assuming that these nodes know the whole
input they don't know the other excise
and they might not know the graph G they
only know their local view in this graph
yeah yeah we're gonna see this exact oh
that's a good question in my model the
prover is gonna be either honest or a
cheating for all the verifiers are
cooperating and honest okay I'm not
gonna talk about like verifies that
they're malicious that's a good
direction for future so maybe this graph
is not of interest maybe just a public
rap that everybody knows okay then I
only care about these inputs and
actually in some cases people don't care
about the individual inputs but only
about the graph okay and you might have
something that cares about both so this
is like the most general
okay so what is the model so we're gonna
talk about public coin particles okay
we're gonna call this distributed a.m.
okay so this is an example of a how
would I would define a two-round
protocol so every node you in the graph
okay it's gonna send some random
challenge are you okay so they don't
have common randomness okay
every node just samples a string ru and
sends it so this is gonna be a L bit
string okay some parameter L the prover
is gonna respond with a personal message
mu okay so this might be a different
message for each and every note again L
bits then the noise are just gonna
exchange are you an mu okay the proof
that they got and the challenge that
they sang with their immediate neighbors
in the graph okay because this is the
only people they can talk to and they
have to decide if to accept or reject in
this case we're going to say that the
proof size is L okay this was the bound
on every single edge okay so the proof
side is gonna be L and if we have more
rounds then L is going to be like the
total bound
on an edge throughout all the rounds so
my input is the graph in all these and
for completeness I want that if X is in
the language then with high probability
all nodes except if soundness says that
if X is not a language there exists at
least one single node ok only one that
you know says I disagree yeah so each
node had no seeds individual input X I
and with vector G he just knows his
immediate neighbors in the graph okay so
you can assume that the nodes have
unique IDs okay and he knows that he can
send message to his neighbors as this
local V of G the issues communication
issue is what is by the way if I make
the graph complete graph cement so we'll
see exactly the limits okay in a second
and they choose communication and we're
exactly going to see the limits of what
is a trivial communication what we're
aiming for okay just the next slide so
in this model I'm not going to assume
any computation limits under under nodes
okay even though our results the nodes
are very efficient but okay generally
I'm not assuming I want abstract this
out so I'm only talking about the
communication
okay rotation Y so if it's two rounds
we'll have like this distributed am
three rounds okay M a.m. in general
distributed IP with our rounds and FN is
like the communication yeah this was
gonna be like public coin and this also
private going even though I didn't
defined what is private going here in
this like yeah I'm gonna talk mainly
about just once in the end or after just
once in the end
okay so let's see very simple example so
suppose your language really has no
inputs though only the graph is is what
you care about and you want to prove
that this crowd graph has a three
coloring okay so what is not the prover
gonna do is just gonna compute this we
call another graph it's gonna send every
node a color okay so this is like two
bits and then they're got just gonna
exchange this color with their neighbors
and verify this this is a legal coloring
okay so graph three coloring when the
language only considers the graph the
communication graph itself is actually a
very simple problem this is non
interactive it suggests an NP
just each of them say with a fee each of
them just say what them think okay if
they all accept I just call this they
accept if one rejects then you can think
you know he has some emergency button he
pushes and he starts communicating this
you know in a different manner but you
want somebody to notice that something
happened I can talk about zero knowledge
at all nothing here is zero knowledge
I didn't say zero knowledge I'm not
protecting any information here is a
system and we'll talk a bit about zero
knowledge idea
okay so now here's the other extreme I
claim that any language can be decided
in this model if you let the proof size
be like enough okay if you let it be
like I can send in square so we suggest
the graph and if you let me send just
the size of all the inputs so really
what can the prover do okay so it just
sent the whole input as a proof okay you
just send it to all nodes every node a
then a verify that their neighbors
received the exact same input so this
way you can force the approver to
broadcast the same message to everyone
okay because if everyone checks that
their neighbors got the exact same
message it must have been the same
message to all of them because the graph
is connected then they just check that
their local view of G and this are
consistent so if I have X I am going to
check that the X I sent is the real one
and my local view of G is what he sent
in the graph so now I have just one node
that knows everything and I didn't
assume any computational assumption so
he can just run in unbounded time and
solve this okay so this is like the
trivial regime of the of this model so
really we're looking at proofs that are
either constant okay even one bit or the
maximum is this
yeah so for this example yeah I just
the smaller doesn't care about running
time our actual results of no to be very
efficient but just a model really
doesn't care about money
see this was between these and what's
called labeling yeah
proof labeling so so so there was first
this notion of labeling which is very
similar on the you trusted the prover
okay and then this was generalized to
proof labeling where you label the nodes
of the graph but you don't trust
approver so you wanted the proof and
this is like an interactive version of
proof later so OneNote sees that the
local gives wrong he raises a flag and
that's enough let's he just rejects the
proof and the soundness says that if X
is not a language one node rejects yeah
and this is by this model like you
cannot really do like it could be that
the instances in the language except you
know one bit of the input and only one
notes is this so really like you have
like this is the best possible unless
you I don't know talk about proximity or
stuff like that
but also anything is a proof of length
zero right just a community no but so
yeah so they can I measure the
communication here as well as the
communication between the nose and the
prover so like it's the same bound okay
so if they want to send something then
this is the proof sighs okay it's both
so the notes can only talk to their
neighbors then that means without
approver they might not even be able to
solve a problem it might be impossible
like if you know something know if you
only allow one round yeah
like here here I allow one round because
it's without loss of generality because
you have approver that can simulate
doing more rounds but let's say you
could have defined a variant where you
talk to the prover for our rounds and
then you talk locally for K rounds and
then you could solve anything with the
number of rounds is enough to just share
all the information
it was like okay this is like a
distributed protocol is always trivial
with enough rounds
okay just send all the information to
one guy and he just solves the problem
we're talking about which problems can
be really efficiently verified with
approver in a distributed manner
okay so a call of hansik sauna defined
this model and they had some result some
results
these were results for specific
languages and mainly languages that
cared only about graph the communication
graph itself this was a graph non is a
morphism and they had also graph
isomerism and some other results just
highlighting these so they had an upper
bound for this problem I'm not gonna
define this problem exactly now it's
some equivalent of the classical graph
99s or McPherson so it's a four round
protocol and the proof size was n log n
ok so this is below what is treble which
is N squared and they also had a log and
lower bound for two grounds okay and
without without the interaction you
actually needed to send like the
trivalent n squared so this was just
really a proof that this model is
actually powerful okay you can go from
things that have to be trivial just to
things that are much less than two
without interaction to have just
approver that sends the proof and that's
it and then they talk and they verify
you don't have like am hmm no it's like
an NP proof it's not non-interactive
right a non-interactive version would be
that the prover sends a proof and then
they talk to their neighbors and that's
it okay yeah but more interactive
version would video the very first send
a challenge to the prover then they get
a response and then they for round so
though it is distributed an a.m. so this
like the number of rounds so our Laurie
methane are linearly starts okay so what
is where where there are results so we
actually have a general compiler so we
can take any will not any a lot of
standard interactive proofs and compile
them to one that are distributed okay
and what we need is some efficiency of
the of the verifier in the standard
proof so if the verifier was somewhat
efficient then we actually get an
efficient distributed protocol and this
maintains the this transformation
maintains the prover complexity
so what do I mean more precisely if I
started with an hour round standard
centralized protocol and the verifier
could run in some bowden time some time
T then I would get a distributed
protocol I would add two rounds so it'll
be R plus two rounds and the proof size
is gonna be T over N times log n ok so
if T was let's say n and then this would
be just a log and proof size and we call
that n is the number of nodes it's not
the input size the input size might be
bigger just you get the example of sweet
coloring yeah you see just think how
would you do we're having student cycle
what we're gonna see like I'm gonna more
than hint
you see bounded you mean like like a
series of tail no the time the running
time is T
[Music]
yes yeah okay so this is like RRR and
this is g'kar so we're gonna see the
exact statement yeah but in general
let's think of just poly log space okay
well so if the verify run in poly log
space or actually entered epsilon space
for small enough epsilon then we get
that we add some constant number of
rounds and the proof size is going to be
log N and this is so this is all going
to be constant depth polio exponentially
1 over epsilon I mean in this one person
so it's just take the DK are like you're
gonna suffer the same things that g'kar
suffer just going to show that you can
actually take the D here come and and
compile this distributed without any
loss just roughly the same parameters so
the guy on the left yeah the graph G and
the input has might have something like
if it's a dense graph and squared and
also the other inputs might be even
larger yes sparse graphs it could be
linear presentation of the graph also
matters yeah but you know it just let's
assume it's always in squared yes yeah
and we're gonna talk about this so I can
always send my neighbors but do I know
this work yeah so you don't know the
graph you don't for our positive you
don't you don't need to know the graph
yeah it's part of the input that is
distributed so you might not know the
graph
these upset things maybe you know the
Griffin some parts can be like easier
general I don't assume you know the
graph also the language can only depend
on the breath so if you know the graph
and the language only depends on the
graphs and everything is trivial so I
start with our own protocol okay and I
end up with the R plus to run protocol I
add two rounds and this is the proof
size this is the proof side this is like
a bound on the number of bits that's
going to be sent on each and every edge
from the verifier to the prover and also
between themselves this is just the
bandwidth
they overall
yeah but as one said if the graph has N
squared time if the graph is a size N
squared and even if you have a simple
linear time algorithm then this will be
like n here you'll get an N log n proof
size so this is not enough okay but
that's exactly why we have these two
compilers okay so you can do things on
large graph but as long as they have
small therefore small space and you get
something much more efficient
okay so what we're going to see is
actually this this compiler and I'm
going to talk about briefly how these
two actually follow from this compiler
okay this is really the the main heavy
lifting
Oh any other questions before
we have some additional results ok these
are like four specific problems we're
not gonna see all of them but just for
comparison like the gni problem so the
previous result was four rounds with n
log and proof size and what we get is
the same number of rounds but we'll make
the size log in and so actually this so
this talk was given by autumn last year
at Simon's here and she stated this
permutation as an open problem and so we
actually one of her techniques to solve
this problem with the proof size of log
in and I don't know if we have time
we're going to see how we actually can
add more rounds to bring the proof size
to log log in and this also saw solves
like a clicker leader election problem
which are maybe have other
[Music]
okay so we're gonna see a protocol for a
very clean problem called set equality
and this is really gonna be the basis
for the compiler so the compiler is
gonna be like a simple reduction for
this and also permutation we're gonna be
a simple reduction for this so this is
like the a clean combinatorial problem
that we solving is really the heart of
of our compiler so what is the problem
so every node has two values okay a and
B actually it has two lists of values
but let's just think of one value okay
so i've like a value a in my left hand
and a value B in my right hand a over
some field which is has some poly n
sites now I'm gonna define the set a as
all the au values okay so all the values
that all note have in the left hand and
B all the B values so all the nodes that
I haven't
okay among all the notes and my goal is
to verify that a equals B as sets as
actually as multi sets okay just the set
of all a values is the same as the set
of all B values with multiplicities
okay and this might be hard guy heck
might have a three here and 10 here and
Chevy might have a 10 and then a seven
and but Chevy might be very far from me
in the graph so I cannot really check
this okay and the idea actually goes
back to Lipton in 89 and we're going to
use reed-solomon codes but in a way that
is invariant to the order and I think we
saw similar things throughout the
workshop so we're gonna encode the set a
as a polynomial and the way we're going
to encode it is not treat the AIS as the
coefficients but rather just treat them
as the solution to this polynomial so
you're just going to define this
polynomial okay where all the A's are
the solutions are the roots and the same
for B and you can you notice that these
two polynomials are equivalent if and
only if the sets are the same okay so
the order of the elements doesn't affect
it doesn't affect this polynomial only
the elements and their multiplicity so
if element had higher multiplicity in
the sense that it will be a root with
Hermann multiples
okay so now what we're gonna do how can
we check the two polynomials are the
same okay so this was used throughout
this week we're going to evaluate them
on a random point okay so we're going to
somehow choose a random point s and
somehow evaluate these polynomials on a
random point so this is our hope okay so
maybe yeah so well it's back to 89 yeah
but yeah might be already we saw a lot
of even after crisp idli like this was
already you say you say booty said we
said so it's a set of elements I don't
care about the order just if you're in
and out but you might be in the sense in
the set but like have three times can be
in the set with multiplicity 3 I don't
know what the bag maybe a bag is a
multiset they're allowed repetition so
five could be in the set with
multiplicity six and three can be in the
set was Muslim multiplicity 2
we consulted for you go girl nothin
which repeats many times you have this
many wounds or signal equivalent would
be that this polynomial will have a volt
at this number
but the multiplicity of the wood is
going to be exactly the multiplicity of
the element in the set so did you ever
say that I've did not repeat twice and
another piece once once then the not
equal the polynomials are the same if
and only if the set are equal as
multi-search exactly with multiplicities
so we reduced this still competing
something more simple okay so now we're
going to see how we can compute some
global function on the rap so like a
hash function that didn't care about the
order of government so you could like
compute it online has four sets
okay so first we're gonna compute a
spanning tree and because we don't know
the graph this is not a trivial task
okay we're going to ask the prover to
send every node you so we're gonna ask
the prover to compute some spanning tree
of the graph and I'm gonna ask the
prover to send the parent of the tree
okay to every node and when I know my
parent then this defines the tree
because every node knows these parents
okay but we don't trust the prover so
we're gonna also ask him to send the
distance from the root and also the idea
of the roots okay
so why are we doing this so the prover
gives you your pointer to your parent
okay but there might be a cycle okay I
might point to somebody that points to
somebody that points to meter there
might be a cycle and also he might give
two trees it might be a forest so we
need to eliminate these two situations
so by sending the distance from the root
and by verifying that my distance is
exactly my parents distance plus one
okay I know that there cannot be any
cycles okay this cannot be consistent on
a cycle and by forcing him to broadcast
the idea of the route I just know that
there's one single group so this is
really a tree and this is gonna be very
useful is gonna help us compute this
polynomial the proof size for this was
log in bits so what is gonna be our
protocol we're gonna first the prover is
gonna send the verifier tree okay along
with the proof that this is a spanning
tree
the verifier now we have a route okay so
we have a unique element he is gonna
choose this element s okay that we want
evaluate the polynomial and you're gonna
send it to the prover the prover is
gonna respond by broadcasting this so
everybody knows the the element is and
he's gonna give us these values okay
what are these values okay I need to
define them so these are the so tu is
gonna be the subtree at node u so if
this was no deal then this is his
subtree okay so what are these values is
the evaluation of the polynomial up to
this subtree okay so if I didn't have a
prover what would I do
I would compute a tree and then I would
have all the leaves send their values to
their parents the parents can just do a
multiplication okay and they send these
values and so on
I'm just asking the prover to give me
all these partial computations okay so
we're gonna verify the consistency of s
so he actually had to broadcast this and
then every node is gonna vary verify
that the product of what he got from all
his children in the tree okay so this is
all the V J's all his children in the
tree times this element au minus s okay
so this is how evaluating the polynomial
only by the point he knows okay it
equals what the prover gave him and the
same for B and if all of this is
consistent then the root must have the
product the whole product okay of the
polynomial
so back
we're taking this polynomial okay and
every node can just compute one part
right every node nodes we be you and can
compute s minus V you okay and we're
just slowly evaluating this up the tree
okay this gives us that set equality has
a three-round protocol right this will 3
rather than if you look at it a bit and
massages you can actually make this two
rounds and that's why exactly I said
that this is an aim so you don't really
have to first commit to the tree and
then start you can actually everybody
would send an S thinking oh I will be
the root and then somebody will see that
I am actually the root
okay they're not getting say yeah so the
login is we needed login for the tree
and also like the field has polian size
so all these things are field elements
so it has like login for justice
leaguers no good that's mean approver
had to send three things your parent so
this is already login bits then your
distance for from the root these are
bits yeah yeah one field many you know
in the MAL au revoir
in general yeah so we have a log and
lower bound for a m4j knife or graph
Nonie's a morphism we don't have better
lower box yeah
okay so let's just see how this thing is
useful before we go to the actual
compiler because we also gonna need
permutation so that's just this
permutation problem so just it's a
simple problem every everybody has just
one value a you okay it's a number
between 1 and N and we want to decide
that this is actually a permutation and
this is useful because the nodes
originally just have unique ids like
your IP or something you don't have like
exact numbering between 1 and n okay
this is a way where the prover can just
give numbering and prove that he did
this correctly so how are we going to
reduce this problem to set equality
so the a values we already have the
eight values and we're just gonna set
the B values to be a 1 plus au plus 1
mod n so this is just my B value and I'm
just gonna prove this by example so
suppose this is the numbers he gave ok 3
1 4 2 and so it's an actual permutation
then the B values are gonna bleep for us
1 mod n so it's going to be 4 2 1 3 okay
and then these sets are actually equal
okay these two sets are equal but if he
lied if we did something like 1 3 2 2
then we're going to get 2 4 3 3 okay
when I do plus 1 and then these sets are
actually not equal
you use the identity as the big values
there's a decent be arbitrary except
with their unique right arbitrary
no this is what I want to solve I want
to get ideas from one to him
that's what I want to solve this
actually for this you don't even need to
assume that they have IDs you just need
to assume that somehow they can talk to
their neighbors like they have some
ordering of their neighbors when I can
talk to neighbor number one neighbor
number two you didn't want to tell the
multigraph this yeah no I'm gonna assume
I know end throughout this talk and I'm
mainly doing you a favor so it depends
exactly like so we've if you assume the
graph is connected and let's say you
have some rough bound on in then you can
you can actually compute it
okay so let's see the compiler so and I
assume I have some protocol pi okay the
standard protocol and I'm gonna first
let the approver assign unique ids 1 to
n to other nodes
ok we just saw how to do that and now
every node is just gonna send ru its
unique challenge ok so in the standard
protocol he would send some long string
R so now every node just sends a small
piece of it the approver is gonna take
all these random challenges he's gonna
treat them as a capital R I'm just gonna
compute what the prover would have sent
back so this is this message m and then
he's just gonna split it evenly to all
the nodes and send each node mu ok so I
really did nothing here and now somehow
magically I need to verify that the
original verifier have had some verifier
that would take the graph G this
challenge R and a response M that it
actually would say yes the question is
how can I simulate this computation so
let's start by assuming that this
verifier it can be implemented by a
circuit
so this is the circuit so every gate is
every node is gonna be responsible for a
gate okay and if the circuit is is
larger than the number of nodes and I'll
just divide the gates evenly between the
nodes so node I is responsible of gay GI
modem and then the prover is just so
assumed let's say we take this gate and
g1 is responsible for this gate the
prover is just gonna send me the value
on this wire the value on this wire and
the output value here okay so these are
three values and I'm assuming here like
constant the constant fénelon constant
panel
and so I'm just gonna locally check that
this computation is correct that the
output wire is the end of the two input
wires okay what is the problem here is
that this output wire for me is an input
wire for this person g4 okay and I don't
know that the value that he gave me as
the output wire is the same value that
he gave somebody else as the input wire
so we're gonna define W to be the set of
all the values of the input wires we're
gonna define W prime to be the set of
all the values of the output wires okay
and now so what I mean the set is gonna
contain like the the name of the wire
and its value okay and now I wanna make
sure that these two sets are the same
set okay he didn't cheat in any place so
this just goes exactly back to back to
set equality
so really the prover is doing the whole
computation for you and then just giving
out all the partial computations and
then using set equality to prove
consistency that they didn't tell here
oh yeah the partial computation was X
and to somebody else Y the circuit okay
so the circuit is so the circuit is the
it's known right it's private it's part
of the standard protocol so the circuit
is known to everybody okay and then if
I'm number four then I know exactly the
gates that I'm responsible I need to
know that okay this is public the
structure of the circuit has nothing to
do with the graph okay if I'm this guy
and this guy is not my neighbor in the
graph okay can I just communicate and
see that we got the same value
so the original protocol had our rounds
then we first gonna just simulate these
are rounds okay and then we need for the
for the compiler two more rounds okay
for set equality and the proof side is
going to be just the size of C okay the
number of gates over n plus log n for
the set equality questions
okay so now going back to what Ron asked
at the beginning of the talk so first of
all where is the graph okay so the graph
is part of the input so it's gonna be
like read by this circuit right the
verify like reads all the input so even
if the graph is large its N squared and
my algorithm is sub linear okay then you
know we just need at least a wire for
every input bit okay so this circuit is
going to be big okay so what we do is
actually give a more direct compiler for
RAM programs as in just in stark
yesterday I don't want to exactly define
what a round program is but this is a
round program and one advantage is you
can do sublunary
algorithms okay and you don't have to
pay the input size and um actually the
this goes back to a work of gamma tile
for memory checking yeah in general it's
a bit more involved compiler but again
reduces to set equality okay the nodes
do read and write to this global memory
that they cannot see the prover tells
them a memory at location at the time T
location I who had the value a and at
the end we want to check that the
consistency between the reads and writes
okay to this big round
so if you'd like sir try to compose it
with the permutation protocol me and you
do get that some people ignore me on the
right and this polynomial just like has
a bunch of terms and like you sort of
bunch the terms together each like node
has it only in terms and then you
essentially do chappal you get to run to
check at this point okay let's go to
zero yeah is there like something some
general framework that captures what can
be done with this I'm not sure after
yesterday I started thinking about
cylinder automata but they okay so the
number of rounds we just added two
grounds for the set equality at the end
the proof size here is going to be T
over N times log n so it's a bit worse
than T over n plus log n in the circuit
so best practice is really sparse graphs
as one said one example is planarity
testing so we have a linear time
algorithm for that so this would give a
three-round protocol with log n size
proofs to test that the communication
graph is actually trainer
you have something an assumption that
what you asked about the graph is like
an end but it's most an np-complete over
there and that we all or and you can ask
anything about the ground
I don't care about any time so ask for
example suppose of the graph is
generalize chess board and the how do
you prove something like there is no
there is no scheme for there for the
black queen
so you had two for here you had to start
with an standard interactive protocol I
have if I don't have even a standard
interactive protocol
yeah yeah
if you need to talk with a booger about
all the reads and writes to
recomputation so that you can do the
offline memory checking algorithm would
you have to pee somewhere some TV time
locked in because each of these reads
and writes have an address in them yeah
you'll have a yeah you'll have a time
stamp you'll have a time stamp in the
proof the time stamp would be like at
point I in the time of the computation
yeah no it's gonna be like last levity
so I I have a yeah for this for this
exact statement I have an underlying
assumption that T is like paulien yeah
if T is like two large anyway this is
not interesting that's why yeah like
depends on the input sizes right so
we're but still this is an efficient
simulation runs the other the other
approach with N squared proofs was you
were doing it yourself verse here you're
preserving the fine
okay maybe I have a question yet try to
map this some story
[Music]
you have this thing with the verifier
raising looks like right is there some
sense that you could imagine that if
there if I were to prove that the
information that he got would make him
ready to flood like so that he would
have some trace which would be what's
raised his transcript the court later
returns to show that indeed there was
reason to yeah but then he can like say
claim he had some random string which he
didn't
yeah that's a very good question yeah so
you'd say that I'm a Cooper's Facebook
who's claiming some behaves in the
network for the factor of communication
and then you want to court the crowd has
to Colonel Weise Island then somebody
says no it's wrong and I have a proof
okay that's a great question so as long
as you command show the Facebook indeed
sent you these messages no no but if you
so you have evidences Facebook sent you
these messages yeah you can produce a
particular random string that makes your
algorithm reject that's proof that
Facebook was cheated
that's true yeah talking about the
instances where excess in the language
so no it depends you want that if he's
exit in the language is somebody said no
then he could not prove that he does not
be able to prove that Facebook is trying
to prove to the facts there's nothing in
the language exactly and then what
you're saying there's no that's the
story that's right and like why any of
these is distribute there
and why is it okay that one person says
I reject I mean you want to somehow say
to it it's a way to yeah yeah so this
depends on the setting but if you just
use this to take a very far in and burn
it in parallel on a supercomputer then
you know you just wait for some
processor to say I reject but the point
is that you want to trust them yes I
have a supercomputer I trust it I just
don't know how to paralyze this heavy
verifier but they're having some other
protocol you know so I'm just saying
yeah you don't need the supercomputer to
have a click okay no matter what the
graph is maybe it's public okay but if
this works for any graph so I don't
require that you have a parallel
algorithm where all nodes can all
processors can communicate and they
don't know the input you just
distributed the input which is very long
the proof and just need somehow that
they are connected it's coming up so is
that like complete in some sense yeah I
don't know it's just very useful for us
yeah if you have a general compiler you
have a solution to set equality of
evolutionary when you put the diesel
you mean deterministic distributed
distributor is donated when you use the
power of probabilities here
not have a like any interactive protocol
with a special case I don't know exactly
a special case like in particular but
they're very connected and the lower
bounds are essentially lower bounds
similar to what well they just assume
that the graph is like 2 clicks and have
one edge going in between and then just
have to fault it Alice and Bob and they
communicate but then the poor vertex to
both Addison both if I forget about the
distributed if I forget about the
distributed and negative just a
communication between polar and verify
oh okay
and when you say that everything is
let's say or no pain or something like
this you are saying that everything can
be communication on one edge so if you
just look at all nodes as one entity you
have to multiply everything by n you
have to multiply everything by n require
something expedition yeah so but if you
compile these protocols you would have
the same communication loss so this T
would be very large like you do need to
at least read the communication so this
T would be very very large
and you get trivial result okay
I don't have much time so let me just
say some nice things so you can actually
use this to compile the our our protocol
and GK our protocol we at least saw this
week some talks about the DKR protocol
so M so the result is if you have small
so if the verifier actually has small
space let's say into the epsilon then
you can have just a constant more rounds
additive constant rounds and the proof
size is going to be log n and similarly
if the verifier or the language okay can
be computed by uniform NC circuits then
you're gonna suffer by additive poly
login rounds and the proof size is gonna
be poly log n and really just one slide
on how we achieve these results
so both protocol you can break up to two
steps okay the first steps does some
arbitrary complicated computation okay
these are all these polynomials and
checking and verifying and evaluating
okay but this is sub linear time okay
this is a small computation but
arbitrary and the second like the most
heavy step of the verifier is actually
evaluating the input on a low degree
extension okay evaluating a logical
extension of the input and a random
point and so very high level this how
these two protocols break down and now
we use the RAM compiler to just
generally compile the first step okay I
don't know what it does just I know that
the running time is small enough so I
just compile this and the second step a
low degree extension this is exactly why
we use the tree so you can actually use
the same kind of computation we did up
the tree as we did with the polynomials
to actually evaluate a low degree
extension so this way really you can
just plug in
Jiki are in error and get and get in get
this
and you don't have to go into all the
details and try to distribute you know
every step of the protocol okay I have
just two minutes just to finish up and
so you know we can get rid of
interaction actually using pH Amir and a
random Oracle this is not like exactly
trivial but it's more or less trivial
because you cannot apply the random work
on the column the whole graph okay
because no single node can do that but
you can get around this and you can
compile these interactive protocols back
to if you know proof labeling scheme so
this would be the equivalent argument
labeling scheme this is a computational
variant analog of the proof labeling
scheme and the zero knowledge here's
just a simple way how to get zero
knowledge okay from relatively heavy
assumptions in particular fully armed
American Krypton so what would I do
I'll just have I'll just generally
compile any protocol have the prover
encrypt all the messages okay and send
them to the so we just do the hokum in
the whole layer protocol encrypted at
the end the node would just get all the
messages from its neighbors its
homomorphic we gonna compute but the
original node would have compute then it
either has an encryption of 0 or
encryption of 1 okay and then the prover
can just interact individually with
every single node and prove that what he
has underneath is actually an encryption
of 0
that's more or less zero knowledge okay
yeah protocol yeah so let me just say
that log and seemed like a natural
barrier for for many problems because
just sending an ID or element filled
everything like too clogged and bits but
we show actually that using a bit more
rounds you can actually go to log log n
bits and sometimes even constant bit
some open problems so it's very hard to
prove am lower bounds and that's why I
have some more restricted models so this
I think is a good model to show lower
bounds
so maybe yes I guess if you have
standard lower bounds I guess so it
depends if you like they talk about the
node being efficient or not
Babur in length increases can't read but
catches on whatever is above emulate
like each other party yeah but then I
can send you order and beads were
charged by 41 because I'm sending you on
one piece but you can put up the graph
right so you can make it into like two
clicks with one engine I think the
problem is that in these protocols it
might be like log in bits per node from
the hood but across all the nerves total
apps have a proton you have to have a
like a high lower bound their square
roots yeah yeah
you can ask what happens if you have
private randomness or maybe the notes
have shared private randomness does this
help and ask about a good versus if
self-transformation in this in this
model of course you can have better
protocols for specific problems okay not
this general compilers maybe these are
problems that you're interested in like
proving things on polynomials and stuff
and then you can have much more
efficient base and of course more
applications
[Applause]
yeah that is a good question so that
doesn't work naively just didn't buy buy
[ __ ] won't work here because it
increases the communication by a lot and
then when you distributed this it just
becomes like but maybe identifying the
problems for which you can do by by move
on in this moment
she's their separation like the whole
like more than like we have the log in
lower bounds 4:00 a.m. and then we can
actually go be below that with more
rounds
that's like constant many more rounds
[Applause]